este jueves el congreso español aprobó
la ley de la eutanasia una propuesta que
contaba con amplio respaldo la
aprobación en el congreso de la ley de
eutanasia supone una gran conquista
social para nuestro país avanzamos en
libertad en derechos civiles y en
dignidad gracias a los grupos que han
apoyado esta norma y a las personas y
colectivos que han trabajado para
conseguirlo
según el texto actual cuando la ley
entre en vigor en 2021 a aquellas
personas mayores de edad que padezcan
una enfermedad grave e incurable que
cause un sufrimiento físico o psíquico
intolerable podrán solicitar ayuda
médica para morir prestación que se
incluirá en el sistema nacional de salud
la familia de maribel tellaeche una
española enferma que recogió miles de
firmas para reclamar su despenalización
muestra su satisfacción una inmensa
alegría porque en un futuro ya inmediato
cientos de miles de personas van a poder
ser libres libres para decidir cómo
vivir y cómo morir y de esa manera dejar
de sufrir innecesariamente manifestantes
y miembros de vividores un grupo
activista que se opone a la ley estaban
fuera del parlamento mientras se votaba
el proyecto es una ley
que es primero y justa va contra todos
los principios mis principios y en
contra de una ley que plantea la
eutanasia como un derecho
es el ridículo
bajo la antigua ley española ayudar a
alguien a terminar con su vida
conllevaba una pena de prisión de hasta
10 años pero más del 80 por ciento de la
población estaba a favor de la
despenalización según una encuesta de
opinión nacional de 2018